The Joe Rogan Experience what was it
like
fighting again after all those years
Hey listen I did this toad this
DMT stuff right and I just I lost that
weight and I said I don't know what
happened I just don't know what happened
I didn't say I'm gonna do this well it's
funny because you talked to me on the
podcast before the first time you came
on and he said I can't even work out
yeah because if I work out my ego get
excited
but I did this toad and they just told I
said he gotta do it he said you have to
do it the toad told you the DMT told you
it's time to fight I lost the weight
and it started off with me at first
fighting Bob staff at first that's right
the K1 event I was there for that I was
there live I mean I was gonna fight yeah
the ring with him he said Mark was a
Queensbury rule but listen the time the
fight off what royal Jones was supposed
to be with Bob Sapp oh really
oh no kidding hell yeah I wouldn't have
to chase this guy all the way
so the next thing you know gotten
um Ray Jones got involved in other
Fighters Holyfield got involved and then
it turned into a fiasco and then the
young guy
Jake Paul yeah Jake Paul he got involved
in and that's how he that's how the
birth of Jake Paul became when you get
challenged by someone who's a a guy like
a Jake Paul does that piss you off is it
part part of it that just like my um no
it doesn't I don't know I think it's
awesome it is awesome
you think it's cool that's awesome
that's awesome that you handle it that
way
because like in a way I mean it's it's
kind of insulting it's Brave it's bold
of him but it's also it's like Jesus
Christ there's levels to this world let
me let me know what I found out
um
this good gentleman um he was a mayor in
this town in the midwest right and I
talked to me for and he was one of those
Stern guys he always got to build paid
always got your lights on nobody's got
everything right and perfect but he
didn't have a good personality and he
almost lost to a guy that didn't do
anything he didn't make either me be
[ __ ] on people's tactics method but
he hung out with the people he smoked
cigarettes with him he drank with him he
ate with him he's going to hang on their
porch with him yeah and that's when you
learn you can't take yourself too
serious
right I mean the world will turn on you
if you take yourself to the states who
the hell am I to take myself too serious
made all this money got this reputation
and now I'm looking at people's
screw facing them down right have a
great life how am I gonna be mad at
somebody really think about it when my
ego is not involved how can I really be
mad at somebody that's beautiful that's
a beautiful attitude and you're so right
because there's so many people that are
so concentrating on they're
concentrating so much on succeeding and
doing great things that was me are you
going to win so bad I wanted to be
somebody so bad it wasn't even funny
yeah and you forget what life is about
life is about thank you life is enjoying
moments life for the balance in life
your legacy is not what you accomplish
is what your children say about you at
the end of the day
they know who you are they know what
you're hiding that you don't want no one
else to see I'm sure you are a fan of
miyamoti Musashi I'm sure coming on the
Japanese warrior book of five rings yes
it was all about balance that was this
whole thing is it like an uh a samurai
has to be an artist you have to be able
to do calligraphy you have to be able to
paint you have to be able to write yes
he felt like if you had any imbalance
like if you were like too aggressive or
too peaceful like any imbalance was
dangerous he's like you had to be like
perfectly centered so you had to be a
person who understood all things yeah
that's true to work everything that's
true but um everybody can um Express
themselves being centered yeah people
have to be totally insane to express
themselves a totally introverted to
express themselves and I don't know why
it's like that I think he's talking
about it from a point of fighting with
swords a self-control yeah I think
fighter that our main problem is
self-control that's I mean for sure yes
yeah and it gets worse as you get more
successful and more destructive and more
you know conqueror you're the [ __ ]
guy in Sports Illustrated you're the
[ __ ] man I mean it's just when you're
a guy who's in a position like you were
in when you were 20 years old like I've
had this conversation with many people
like do you understand the kind of
self-control it would take to be the
baddest man on the planet and you're
only 20.
it's a crazy position to be in so like
imbalance at that point your life was
almost impossible
like to be like it was a no balance it
was strict fighting no grocery strict
it's too much distance this it was this
if I that was bad oh God [ __ ] I can't
make that happening I got spawned do
better tomorrow hmm that was bad okay I
gotta move my head when I got hit today
I got a black guy archived but because
it's gonna be mad at me if you see me
through this if you see me get hit and
it was just everything was on being
perfect do you think that that's what it
takes to make someone who is as good as
you as young as you you have to be
completely obsessed
type of person and at that point in time
I mean I mean to achieve what you
achieve so quickly too you know like you
met cause when you were like what 13 12
12. so from 12 to 20. I mean that's wild
that's a wild 12 to 19 he died when I
was 19 but the fact is um that I I um
I put so much of myself into buckling my
emotions and everything
that was magnificent that was great but
then when I came to life it was
disastrous right imagine being imagine
being that God is just so boom always in
the person saying hey hey guess what hey
baby I love you hey hey what's up hey
hey and I'm just that manic type of
person with everything yeah yeah
[Laughter]
oh man